um it's going to be so cool i think
people will have nfts that get published
and scientists should earn royalties for
that as people trade hands on these like
things that have such important impacts
in society
yeah so i mean i think the scientific
paper is not the ideal medium to
communicate science through
yeah that's that's what we're doing with
new limit it's early days and we're
basically uh recruiting the founding
team and uh more people for that team
and we've got some office space set up
in in redwood city california
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video i had
the great pleasure of speaking with two
guests brian armstrong ceo of coinbase
who along with patrick joyce a medical
student launched the platform research
hub
here we chat all about research hub and
how blockchain technology can aid
sharing of scientific research
and we also discussed brian's recent
longevity company announcement new
limits and how they both viewed the
future of research i hope you enjoy our
conversation
so hi brian hi patrick thank you bae for
joining me today and welcome to the
chicken science show it's great to have
you both on here
thanks for having us yeah i'm really
excited to be here
great thank you um so on my youtube
channel i also talk a lot about research
papers and try to break them down to my
audience and explain exactly um the
latest research and so one thing that i
often find one of the reasons why i do
this is because i feel like there's
often a need to try and communicate
science um to the community and a good
way to do that is to kind of digest a
paper in a kind of shortened format
because it can take you know hours to
actually read a paper properly
um and so together you have launched a
research hub which effectively is a
platform where academics can upload
research papers summarize them discuss
them with other academics um and also
even propose different theories around
their field of interest
and in reward for this they get given a
research coin and so i guess my first
question is uh where did this idea for
research have come from and how did you
guys meet how did the whole thing kind
of arise
yeah well i mean
i can jump in and start and joyce i'll
turn it over to you too so by the way
eleanor we we're both big fans of your
papers uh and your videos that you've
helped playing those papers i think it's
just making science so much more
accessible which we're both passionate
about
but um yeah i mean joyce and i really
met a year or two ago and we had both
sort of independently been thinking
about this similar idea which is that we
both felt like
scientific research was kind of broken
it was sort of inefficient and
you know i came like
joyce would tell his story too i came
from more of like an open source
software
point of view thinking about how could
scientific research be more like open
source software so
in scientific research today people kind
of often operate in silos
they're sort of guarding their secrets
closely you know from the other labs
there's a real scarcity mindset around
funding and then the whole process of
getting peer-reviewed and put in these
journals is just very slow and
cumbersome
and you know it doesn't really never
really made sense to me why are there
these big paywalls why are there big
delays even during covid we saw some of
these rules got thrown out the window
and people would
publish to the pre-print servers you'd
see peer reviews appearing on twitter or
medium you know within 24 hours and like
the whole pace of science just
accelerated during covet out of
necessity and it kind of begs the
question you know why can't it happen
that way all the time you know faster is
not always better you want to make sure
you're going for high quality and
reproducibility but
um i don't think there's any reason why
it needs to be done the same way it's
been done you know for the last hundreds
of years um and one other thing that
really jumped out to me was
that why why do we still use the pdf as
the format of
a how do we publish research you know
it's like in open source software
software is never done it's like you put
out a draft today you get comments on it
you're always shipping you know version
2.3 2.4 2.5 software is never done it's
always evolving and so you know i think
joyce and i share this vision of
creating the future of the scientific
paper i mean today we're going to start
with pdfs because that's how a lot of
the science is done we just want people
to be able to discuss it and prioritize
it and get interesting
access to interesting papers and maybe
they wouldn't have seen otherwise but
the future of that is probably these
electronic lab notebooks that allows
people to publish not only the text but
also the data and the and the code
behind it so it's more reproducible and
then it's a it's a ever living document
that can have a community you know input
from the community and updates pushed
from people who maybe you've never even
met and it's more collaborative and open
there's lots of other things we could
figure out like you know how to fix
funding and all kinds of stuff but i
don't know joyce you have a really
interesting background maybe you should
talk about how you came to the same
conclusion independently
yeah totally so i'm a huge science nerd
during undergrad i was really lucky and
i got to do research in a hopkins tumor
biology lab looking at the epigenetic
signatures of different cancer cell
lines i fell in love with
bench research i started a phd program
in molecular biology and biochemistry um
was also very lucky in that i got to
work in a couple of very cool labs one
specifically was in synthetic biology
for a pi who had had multiple nature
papers and i just remember he was like
an early career researcher maybe like uh
early 30s
was coming up for a grant review and
there was maybe six months where he was
just walking on eggshells continuously
because despite the fact he was
essentially at the top of his heel his
field with multiple nature papers there
was no guarantee that he was going to
receive the funding he needed in order
to like continue his lab employ like the
grad students that were working for him
keep his kids in school i remember him
like specifically saying like if i don't
get this i'm gonna have to move out of
boston and like like put my kids in a
new school and i was like oh man that's
it feels crazy for someone who had had
so much success in the past
um i have a bunch of stories that were
ridiculous from my phd program another
one which stands out was
another member of our lab was on their
ninth year normally a phd in wecker
biology is like five to seven years
so they were in their ninth year
essentially had completely run out of
funding they were sleeping on a friend's
couch and paying for their own reagents
and experiments out of their own pocket
just to maybe get the results they
needed in order to graduate with a phd
so they could go make like 50 plus k as
a postdoc somewhere and so to me it was
clear that um like an individual's
like effort
and essentially desire to succeed
um
a lot of you have to have the cards have
to fall right in science in order for
you to have like a successful career i
think in the us it's like one percent of
first-year phd students end up being
like research professors
so i ended up kind of seeing this
landscape where the funding of science
caused this like kind of like low
quality of life for people who are
working so hard to create new knowledge
and so i ended up
leaving with the masters started medical
school very passionate about mental
health and psychiatry
the medical school i went to was great
in that they get you into the clinic
like in the first week of medical school
and so um i saw like firsthand a lot of
medications that had really um
unintended consequences
just like a quick anecdote i remember
one patient when i was shadowing a
family medicine physician
who um when she was younger had asthma
and so
took corticosteroids for asthma and kind
of um stayed on this like corticosteroid
treatment for her entire life and
eventually um like over the course of
like a decade or two ended up like
eroding her gi tract so she was unable
to actually like eat normally had to
have like a like a stomach tube and have
food through that because of this like
seemingly innocuous medication that was
used for asthma throughout her whole
life
and so
like um in psychiatry there are also
lots of examples of drugs that should be
much better than they are and i thought
to myself um
i think that the infrastructure for how
basic research and like academic
research is funded and published kind of
is this like bottleneck in uh like new
product creation on the clinical side of
things and so um i ended up taking a
year off medical school and working on a
project where the idea was to try and
create new incentives for
um
basically publishing research openly
reproducibly and then directing funding
to the people who are doing the best
work and so brian and i had similar
ideas ended up meeting kind of
collaborating and we've been working on
research hub for about two years
awesome now and also i completely agree
i'll see from my side that's why i see
that there's
many kind of like barriers um in place
and the way like academia is structured
um and this is why like i was really
interested when i heard about research
hub um and so how exactly does your
platform work and how are you how does
it actually try and solve these problems
joyce you want to start off
yeah sure
so right now in academia the way that
you kind of like prove that you're
worthy for grant funding and then
eventually tenure like career stability
is by publishing so if you're you know
my uh pi in boston who had multiple
nature papers in theory you're
demonstrating your value to someone who
wants to fund research and so you can
basically earn funding and then over
time an institution will give you tenure
or tenure and you have career stability
um this is like a bibliometric reward
structure it's like a library-based
metrics publication metrics
and so this worked for a really long
time basically since like the beginning
of funding science in the 1600s when the
first journal like existed and there
were like you know rich patrons who
would give like louis pasteur money in
order to like you know mess around with
like glass pipes or whatever um and
we've stayed with that system the only
issue is that
people have gotten very good at gaming
it
so
um
when you're in academia
your goal is to publish as much as you
can not necessarily like do the best
science those are sort of different
things
they talk about perverse incentives in
academia like there's like salami
slicing um there's a reproducibility
crisis like it's it's better to have a
big headline than it is to have like a
very rock solid paper even like studies
have shown that like if you publish
negative results it can actually hurt
your career so what people will do is
like if their thesis isn't proven by
their experimental results they'll just
take the results and put them in the
desk drawer so that way nobody ever sees
them again this is a huge issue because
it's like there's all the science that's
happening and this old school incentive
structure that kind of just was
grandfathered in ends up producing all
these unintended behaviors among like
the scientific community where if you
had a plastic reward structure for
instance using research coin maybe you
could actually like study how incentives
cause different behaviors among
academics and try and create rewards
that incentivize the best behaviors so
rather than just saying hey like we're
going to give money to whoever publishes
the most we could say hey we're going to
give money to whoever produces the most
reproducible science or you know whoever
is like thinking about the most like
uh
novel ideas or it could be literally
anything using uh tokenomic structure so
the idea with research hub is to try and
create an infrastructure where you can
reward behaviors that actually make
science as a whole better and as brian
said we're starting with pdfs first
where people can essentially earn tokens
for openly discussing scientific
literature but i think there's a lot of
different directions this could go in
the future um especially with the input
of like our awesome community of people
like you eleanor who like exist in this
world you know and actually have
personal experiences with it and have
great ideas probably better than brian
and i do ourselves on how to make things
better
yeah totally i think
there's a lot of good pieces coming
together here i mean you know so that v1
is really all right let's just take the
paper like make a modern web app for
pre-print servers you know archive and
bio archive are a huge step in the right
direction because it just made it
science papers more accessible but those
applications you know they're kind of
old now they look like they're from 10
years ago or something so first step was
just let's make a modern web application
where people can discuss and rank um
these papers and earn this reward token
for for adding it just like if you were
reading interesting papers already every
week might as well put them there it's
kind of like a journal club but it's the
new the new journal is what we call hubs
people are uh aggregating these papers
and uploading them and whatnot and then
the v2 is like okay we're now we've
shipped our v1 of an electronic lab
notebook feature it integrates you know
jupiter notebooks and um
we think that people hopefully i think
they may be kind of more
people earlier in their academic career
or things like that but they'll start to
publish
papers not via traditional mechanism on
a pdf but maybe start with drafting it
and doing collaborative science and
putting it in an electronic lab notebook
by the way they can also then go submit
it to a journal afterwards but um
publishing in that format no longer the
pdf the electronic version with the data
in the code would be the v2
and then i think
in the future we may even allow people
to actually go in there and license
you know ip or breakthroughs to go
commercialize that those kind of
scientific breakthroughs because there's
a whole other issue we haven't got to in
this life cycle which is usually in
universities when they have the tech
transfer office and you know how do
scientific breakthroughs get
commercialized into products so that
millions of people in the world can
actually benefit from it there's this
huge gap between these two worlds so
that's kind of our progression is like
yeah
better ranking and discussion of papers
electronic papers
now we can make it easier for them to be
the tech transfer office into
commercialization and all of this is
kind of incentivized with this reward
token we've created research coin to
help the community that's coming in to
build all this content and create it to
be rewarded for that so that's the rough
approach that we're taking
cool now you've explained that really
well i'm so in terms of research itself
obviously i've been on the platform i've
had a bit of a play around myself and
uploaded some papers um and so
on for people who also want to kind of
join in so they have to have you've
mentioned tokyonamex and researchcoin do
you have to have any kind of
crypto understanding to be able to join
the platform or is it literally anyone
if they want to to join can join
yeah so we made it really simple for
people to join and contribute even if
they have no knowledge of crypto i mean
frankly i think a lot of scientists
probably have a lot of skepticism about
crypto so it's not even something we
really focus on on the website it's sort
of like
if you if you didn't look closely you
might just think that people are
uploading just like you've seen on
reddit or hacker news or twitter you
know every social platform out there has
some kind of a like button or upvote
button so in a way it's something that's
very familiar to everybody you don't
need to go create a crypto wallet or
anything you're just kind of
accumulating research point um just like
you would on reddit accumulating karma
points but the difference here is that
if you want to you can actually withdraw
research coin and you know in the future
you might be able to use it on an
exchange or something like that
you might be able to you can also by the
way transfer research point like if you
want to support other scientific um
you know content on research hub you can
use it to support like in the future we
may even have the ability people to fund
research on the site using research coin
um
yeah so we've thought about that a
little bit i mean joyce maybe do you
want to talk about the tokenomics and
how we've
made allocated the different portions of
research coin to the community and
foundation and whatnot
yeah definitely so um we have 60 of the
total token supply initially we minted
uh billion uh tokens where sixty percent
are uh earmarked to be distributed to
the community so in theory we plan on
giving out about five percent a year
through um actual activity on the
platform like people who post papers
discuss papers
essentially generate content and then
also we have a dow decentralized
autonomous organization where the
community is able to essentially help
govern the platform using the token and
so we also have people who perform
services for the dow can also earn these
tokens for instance
we have a couple of really passionate
community members who actually helped us
get an interview with the founder of
scihub so um they're
like able to speak russian and were able
to translate for her during an interview
and so
um we helped kind of incentivize this
like community building behaviors by
using research coin so it's a it's a
really cool thing where
um
everyone who has a token is all of a
sudden on the same team and has
incentives aligned and feel empowered to
be able to influence the direction of
our product and community so
yeah the the idea is that when you
reward people directly for certain
behaviors using a coin
you can actually influence the exact
behaviors that they're doing rather than
the sort of like uh
like secondary uh process of oh let me
publish and then eventually my cv will
be worth enough uh to convince the gates
foundation or the nih to be able to fund
me so it's like a direct reward for
doing good behaviors that can change
over time as we learn more about how our
user or user interactions actually are
influenced by the coin
cool i'm so in terms of um the platform
as well is there any kind of major
challenges that you think um you face at
the moment so one of them of some of
most like social media platforms you
need people using the platform to kind
of get the interactions going so besides
like i guess bringing in a larger
community to the platform what kind of
challenges do you think you're going to
face to reach your goals
yeah well you know there's a lot of
challenges in any kind of new startup
you know you have to make something that
people want to use right and we've
developed this initial v1 product i
think it's a good start but it's a long
ways from where our ultimate vision
wants to be so the people the initial
early community that's there already on
research hub and we host a community
call
every week which people can join our
slack if they want to participate more
but you know it's this really passionate
kind of core initial group and so we're
we're like really hugging them close and
getting their feedback and we the whole
team that's building the app today is
probably only about five people it's a
handful of engineers um a designer a pm
and you know really joyce and you know
whatever time spare time i have i try to
help out here and there but um it's it's
an it's an early app but the people who
are passionate about it today which is
this initial small group they can see
the potential in it but they they know
that it's not quite there yet today so
yeah i mean basically we're going out
and getting the initial um
seeds of community members and what
we've asked some people to do actually
is to become editors on some of these
hubs it's kind of like editors of a
journal
um
and people earn research coin for doing
that but it's really we're just asking
editors like hey if you're seeing
interesting papers in
this hub every every week or two just
submit them to the site maybe help
curate if you see bad content
um that's not scientific you could help
you could help moderate it a little bit
and that's been our sort of initial path
to get some of these initial hubs
booted up but i think it's going to be
quirky and weird for a while you know i
always make this analogy like um when
youtube first started
it was
people putting videos of cats and like
you know just very quirky stuff and um
but now youtube is like bigger than
having a television show you know like
if you have a lot a million subscribers
on youtube it's like way better than
having a tv show on cnbc but that that
didn't that took you know 10 20 years
for that to flip and so
similarly we're seeing some kind of
initial early adopters of research hub
that are they're not like the most
mainstream things out there like if
you're a tenured professor you probably
still want to put your stuff in nature
but our goal over time is to flip that
on its head and just say you know what
if if you need to grow your career like
you can do it on this platform where you
can interact live with your
people who are benefiting from the kind
of research you're doing you can
interact live with your collaborators
you can even get kind of rewards for
doing that
hopefully introductions to better
funding all kinds of things so anyway
just like every startup we're building
something new and it's it's a
lot of little things to get right along
the
way
to kind of or add on to that too um a
lot of our early communities early
career researchers
as i mentioned earlier in the us it's
like one percent of first-year phd
students end up becoming professors
so it's like pretty difficult to become
a pi like you have to overcome a lot of
odds and it's like within this extremely
competitive job market so when i've been
seeking feedback from people a lot of
really well established professors um i
think that they're hesitant
to sort of buy into this whole new
structure for trying to like judge the
merit of a research paper right because
like they've had success in the current
system and it's super hard to do so so
um yeah i think over time
as we have more community members and
like more like high quality content on
the site i think we'll be able to win
them over but a lot of the other side of
that are like uh post-docs like grad
students who want to be doing academic
research but they don't necessarily see
an avenue for themselves to be doing it
just because of the extremely
competitive job market so
they see us as a potential like exit
from academia where they'd be able to in
theory
like earn a living earning these coins
by doing what they want to do which is
uh academic research on their own not an
industry kind of like self-directed
through a website
yeah just one more thing you made me
think of too so as joyce mentioned you
know we're planning to give away about
five percent of the supply of research
coin per year uh for the first 10 or i
think it was 12 years until we get to
that um that 60 allocation then we'll
probably issue more over time but you
can imagine you know if you're one of a
thousand people
on the site but we're distributing five
percent every year that you get a much
bigger share than if we were you know if
there's a million people on the site you
know five years from now or something
and you're still distributing five
percent every year and so there's
definitely um this is one of the
theories that we're testing here which a
lot of people in the world are testing
right now with dows and
you know issuing reward tokens and
whatnot which is
can
can this mechanism help solve a little
bit of the cold start problem that
startups have of building that community
because historically you know airbnb and
uber and like these communities you had
to have these um
it was so hard to get them going in the
early stages but once they got going it
had this huge flywheel effect and so
um we'll see i think i think crypto
could be an interesting way to help a
little bit of that cold start problem
but there's no substitute for just you
have to build something that's useful
for people in the world and so um we're
keeping our eye on firmly on that as
well
yeah exactly and well so far research
how at least the identity seems very
useful in terms of being able to
summarize data so you get a quicker
access or a better understanding of a
research study in a shorter period of
time as well as having the ability to
discuss and comment on other work and
even to have easy access to different
disciplines you wouldn't often read
um and so obviously yeah research hub is
solving a lot of problems in academia
but do you think there are any problems
still in academia that you don't think
research hub will be able to address or
um yeah other thoughts
so so one good example i think is like
access to academia um for instance like
a lot of the like major institutions are
in specific spots in the world and if
you're not born in a certain place it's
really hard for you to gain access to
those locations
um
so like research hub is an online space
right like there's no laboratory space
like there's not a lot of like um i
guess education uh so essentially like
you can contribute content and earn
tokens for it but like the the
educational piece of it isn't totally
there at the moment um so yeah i think
access to academia is something that we
don't necessarily address in kind of our
uh first iteration
yeah i get i i think it's a really good
question the only other one i think
think of for me is like if we want to
try to improve reproducibility for
instance
i think
you know you may you might have a study
that's fairly low cost to reproduce and
you can put a bounty almost up there and
like go get a check mark on your paper
okay this person reproduced it or
something but if you have you have a
very expensive long-term study or like
you need a large hadron collider or
something to do your physics study it's
like
i don't know how research hub is not
probably going to be able to help with
some of those like massive
basic science really expensive questions
but
a lot of research you know you can move
the needle for like ten thousand twenty
thousand dollars right now so it's not i
think there's a huge segment we can help
today and maybe over time if it gets
bigger
with more and more funding and resources
we could tackle bigger things too
yeah they're really good points i mean
so obviously at the moment it's about
uploading pdfs and obviously taking
material from actual journals and so um
i guess one thing that often my ideas i
train around with like um other phd
students i talked to is um where they
see like the future of journals in 10 or
plus years and whether that is the most
effective way of communicating the
current research as we've already
discussed there's issues with
like how long it takes to write a paper
delays um and getting out and getting it
accessible to everyone and so you know
one way i feel like i try to bridge the
gap is by making videos so i feel like i
i'm quite a visual learner i think it's
important still to show like the actual
graphs and data um
and try to basically highlight the key
points so you don't have to like not
waste time but spend so much time um
actually trying to read for a paper i'm
gonna say what like do you think there's
still a feature for pdf journals and i
like i think you've already somewhat
touched on it but like how would you
see the future of scientific research
yeah well joyce you should jump in too i
mean
one thing you just made me think of is
we are very passionate about this idea
of making science more accessible as
well and i think your videos are such a
great example of that like you know i'm
kind of a visual learner too and i find
it quite hard to digest
like a whole paper much less 10 papers
in a day or something sometimes people
tell me like oh i went and skimmed like
10 papers to get a sense of what's going
on like how do you even do that i have
no idea how people do that
you know and then i think that a lot of
papers they suffer from this idea it's a
little bit of like an ivory tower type
thing or something where they're almost
trying to use the fanciest language
possible to like because the the real
audience in their mind for this paper is
maybe the 10 other people in the world
who are really in that field who it's
like they're writing it for their peers
not for
the broader um the broader community so
you know i think a lot about wikipedia
right like wikipedia
the usually the introductory paragraphs
of any wikipedia article if you have a
basic even high school education you can
kind of understand what's happening in
that article but that doesn't prevent
the article from getting into really
technical topics later down and you can
kind of go as deep as you want right and
so
you know i we thought about this
actually be cool for any paper on
research hub
the author or maybe anybody who
submitted it they could almost like put
up a bounty and just say i want to have
like an explainer video for this paper
because i just want to help more people
understand it or maybe we can write a
summary of it in plain english
um and so
we thought about that it'd be cool to
like kind of have a service where
anybody could get an explainer video
created or something like that but
um i don't know joyce what do you think
about the future of journals and
research
yeah so i mean i think the scientific
paper is not the ideal medium to
communicate science through it's just
like as i mentioned earlier this like
grandfathered in kind of like tradition
because it's always been that way
even like the idea of like oh here's an
introduction here's a method section you
know here's my results discussion like
it's it's just kind of like a like a
traditional type of format um
one thing i'm really excited about are
micro publications
so uh one of the big issues with a
scientific paper is it takes like a
really long time to produce like from
the time you do your first experiment to
when you collect all your data it's when
you analyze it when you actually like
write the manuscript to then submitting
it for peer review getting like feedback
back making changes then submitting it
again and then and when it's actually
published i think it's like in chemistry
and biology normally there's almost a
year delay from when you actually like
forget about even doing the research
like submit the paper for peer review
and then it's eventually published even
during covid like um preprints were
great because you could get information
out immediately but there would be uh
peer-reviewed publications that would
just be completely out of date because
they're like from four months ago and so
it kind of like this like totally
unnecessary temporal delay that exists
because of the structure of a scientific
paper i think you know slows down
academia as a whole and so one of the
things that can happen in the future
kind of like similar to how twitter has
like a you know character limit on
information
is micro publications where if i do one
experiment i can you know put it into a
post publish it earn tokens off it do my
next experiment publish that publish
everything throughout the course of the
entire research project and then
synthesize it at the end publish it
collect feedback and have live version
control so everything's happening in the
open anyone can see what i'm publishing
at any given moment i can like earn
funding in theory from every piece of it
and then um the end result of this would
be
like real-time science rather than
having something that's like
communicating results that i actually uh
like collected like two or three years
ago so to me the really exciting thing
is maybe moving past the scientific
paper to a more like like stream of
consciousness type of science where
anyone can learn and use the information
that's being produced in real time
that's such a really interesting idea
and i was going to quickly comment and
say that that summer does sound maybe at
times it could be a bit overwhelming or
like too much information overloads but
then at the same time i think even in
the current system i'm already
overloaded with papers that i don't read
so yeah i do i think that that's just a
big problem on its own is how we like
digest
all the content that's produced on a
daily basis
um but that's a really interesting idea
um and so like besides like the
publishing aspects do you like what kind
of duration do you think we might start
to see some of these changes
yeah well i think so we've got our v1
out um we have even a v1 of our
electronic lab notebook out right so
we'd love people to go out and test that
and give us feedback on it it's still in
the very earliest stages um
you know i think that
my hope is
i don't know joyce tell me if you agree
i think in the next year or so we could
probably get
a really pretty well-functioning
electronic lab notebook out there that's
fully compatible with jupiter notebooks
and all that stuff and then um
you know but this is going to be a 10
year journey like i we i'm a big
believer in like the 10-year overnight
success so we're just like gonna keep
our heads down keep relentlessly making
improvements
and um
my hope is like we get that early
community to just keep um it growing and
growing so
i don't know joyce anyone adam yeah one
one thing i'm really excited about is
we're working with a quantum biology lab
at ucla and this is a really interesting
group they're super talented scientists
but just due to the nature of their work
quantum biology which is a very like
cutting edge new field they have a hard
time getting funding
in the us the nih they'll fund like
quantum physics and then they'll fund
like biochemistry and molecular biology
but this is sort of like a intersection
of two fields where they just kind of
like get like passed over by the big
funding agencies so these are like
incredibly talented scientists who just
due to this like completely inefficient
funding system they're willing to
produce content
like aimed towards the general audience
in order to attract funding from people
who might be interested so to me this is
like a really cool like incentive
situation where these super talented
scientists like are essentially going to
share
micro publications that are um targeted
at lay people and it's like a it's a
very technical field
but they're they're publishing with the
thought process of i need to get the
average person engaged so that way i can
raise awareness of this field so that
way eventually the nih will be like oh
yeah this is totally worthwhile you know
these this lab has like 100 000 twitter
followers and everybody's really excited
about their work so
yeah i think um the ability to help
like channel resources to people who are
doing very exciting work i think is
something that we'll be able to do in
the next year and i'm very excited about
it
oh um so you kind of touched on an
interesting point which is obviously
we've been talking so far at the kind of
like the publication and um release of
the the data that's collected but
thinking backwards to like the structure
of like a research group itself with
like um
post-docs phd students and like a pi a
group leader how do you think that this
like new future way or publishing
research might might actually affect the
structure of like research labs oh this
is this is like my favorite question
the one thing that i think is crazy and
i actually have a friend who left
academia who's a super talented um uh
phd student like optical physics but um
one thing that just blows my mind is a
pi right like the way you get to be a pi
is you like do good research and you
write good papers and then eventually
like
someone says oh hey you're worthwhile to
be a professor and then you go from a
researcher to a manager and grant writer
and so like there's not a lot of
training for these things it's like
you're trained to be a researcher and
then all of a sudden like you shift into
this totally different role that just
like the academic like infrastructure
forces you to and it's kind of like a
waste of talent to a certain degree so i
think one thing that research hub will
be able to help with a lot is um
take away some of the like
um you know boring work of like writing
grants um one thing we find very
inspiring is fast grants um have you
heard of this program
it was a basically to help like
streamline coveted funding um a couple
cool people got together and they were
like hey here's just like a google form
like we're gonna have people apply for
funding you just need to send like five
paragraphs about what you're working on
and then like update us once a month
with one paragraph and so rather than
like taking months to write a grant
where like you get rejected most of the
time it's like a super simple
streamlined i can spend an afternoon
describe my project and like maybe get
funding and so if we could help
um pis essentially get back to actually
doing research rather than having to be
like managers and grant writers i think
that that would kind of change the
structure of a lab in a really good way
where you can have the most talented
scientists doing the actual science
which
i think will have really cool downstream
effects
yeah i agree
it yeah it's almost like
right now every lab has to have um all
these talents in one place like the fun
the fundraiser and the communicator and
the experimentalist and you know the
fact checker or whatever and
um it's almost like you know previously
every company had to had to run their
own data center and manage their own
servers and like now we have aws and so
you can kind of you know offload the
undifferentiated burden you know one
might say to
other places and so
i think in the future you'll see
research happen differently where maybe
yeah maybe the fundraising piece is done
by
done through a website or something like
research hub or maybe even you'll have
teams of researchers that they're not
physically in the same location right it
depends on what kind of research you're
doing sometimes you need to still be in
that laboratory or whatever but there's
collaborations that could occur in
various fields that um you know somebody
comes in and provides a piece of the
solution
that you you've actually never even met
them they're like somebody on this on
this site i mean i've personally had
that experience in the software world
and it's kind of a magical thing you're
stuck on some problem
and some kid on the other side of the
world like submits a pull request in and
it's like whoa that's kind of a cool
idea and you don't even know who this
person is right
and so i think you could see a little
bit more decentralization if you will of
of that how science is done i'm you're
seeing bits and pieces already like
there's people um you know crowdfunding
some some studies online and
finding participants for the study
online and so anyway you can see more
and more of these pieces coming together
the lower friction we can make it for
this to happen i think the the faster
we'll make progress in society
you made me think of one other thing too
which was
when we were talking earlier which is
that i think the incentive structure
around science today there's sort of
this
false currency if you will about
citations and so people are very driven
to
get more citations in their career to
advance to advance because it's um
there's not like a true economy you know
if you do have a scientific breakthrough
and it's hard it's very very few
scientific breakthroughs actually ever
get commercialized and the
you know revenue upside of those
products doesn't get shared with science
and the scientists who actually create
it except in rare rare cases like you
can imagine
you know chinentec i think came out of
the tech transfer office at stanford and
i think stanford made a bunch of money
from that i don't know i don't know if
the original scientist did but
most scientific papers are really just
like they're taking an existing idea and
putting a tiny iterative thing on it to
get citations it's not actually they're
not aligned incentives are not aligned
in science to go solve problems for
real-world people and that's okay
sometimes you want to have some basic
science that's just like who knows how
this will ever be used but i also think
it's good to align incentives and so
hopefully we're streamlining that
process a little bit where not only with
research coin but eventually you'll be
able to just license this
stuff right on the site almost like in
the open source world we have the mit
license or the apache license you know
you don't have to do a bespoke custom
agreement for every piece of open source
software you can just oh it's the
license do i want to use it
boom and you and you're off and you can
go commercialize some products so
again in the specialization category
it's almost like we're having
entrepreneurs
um
do their role and scientists can do
their role and they can bridge the gap a
little bit with some of these tools
to kind of add on that to that idea too
with the the currency of citations like
one of the the worst parts about this is
the most valuable citations exist in
journals where the content is published
behind paywalls and the authors
themselves don't get to keep rights like
they sign a way that writes their paper
to this publisher and so one of the
things that like we can do long term
with research coin
is uh try and uh disintermediate this
system
where we can help authors keep ownership
of their own content and share it as
brian said under like these open source
licenses that anyone is able to use um
there are these crazy stories where like
authors will publish in a journal and
then like
share their own paper somewhere and then
end up like seeing like legal
repercussions for it just because of the
current structure and like i personally
don't think that that's okay so i think
that we can use financial incentives in
order to help empower researchers to
kind of like own their own content and
share it you know how they feel like
they want to share it rather than how
like some other company thinks is best
for their bottom line
well that makes me really excited to
hear as a researcher um and you also
raised the really important point about
citations and that kind of someone also
goes back to funding as the more
citations you have for works often more
likely to lead to more funding um and it
kind of raised an interesting idea that
this year in particular i mean maybe
it's been going on longer than i've
noticed but different uh i guess like
blockchain based technologies are being
employed to help fundraise for different
research as well so i mean earlier this
year i heard of fisa dao which is trying
to fundraise for longevity projects and
it's also something i've recently come
across i didn't fully understand called
get coin which i think is also for uh
fundraising so i'm just wondering if you
could both comment on how you see this
overlap between blockchain technology
and funding academic research
joyce want to start i mean we both get
to chat about this for a while but
yeah so one of the uh really cool things
i think about the blockchain industry
right now is it's like very experimental
people are trying out like all kinds of
different ideas like this is a huge
cliche but it's like a cambrian
explosion of different ways to like
potentially fund science so like as you
mentioned uh like bitcoin um that model
can be used to potentially fund research
projects i think vita dao does something
where like if you hold the token you own
some kind of like ip rights uh to the
like research project that eventually
works so that's nice because it actually
like gives funders something back for
like spending their research uh or
research funding um
with research coin one of the best parts
is that we have this like sort of easy
to change incentive structure so over
time we're going to have like an
evidence-based reward scheme
where in theory like we can like learn
from these different models and employ
the ones that are most effective even
like i've seen like uh projects are
publishing nfts right now of like the
figure like the most popular figure from
their paper in order to like you know
potentially like earn a couple k of
funding for their next project so i
think there's a lot of really cool
things uh happening right now in a sort
of like thought experiment kind of
fashion and a couple of them are going
to catch on and i think like make it a
lot easier for the average person to
become a scientist
yeah
but we're definitely seeing a lot of
exciting fundraising opportunities come
together with dows and crypto and the
nft one joyce mentioned i think is
really interesting you know
um i remember reading a long time ago
that uh bill gates actually went and
bought a copy of the da vinci notebook
um i think it was the codex or something
like that and you know
why did somebody want to have an
original copy of that in their
collection and well it's it's kind of an
inspiring document a little piece of
science early science you know and so i
actually i do think that um research
papers there if you wanted to mint an
original of it you know people who just
really really love that particular
breakthrough in science i mean imagine
like the double helix or like whatever
kind of inspiring one you can think of
it's going to be so cool i think people
will have nfts that get published and
scientists should earn royalties for
that as people trade hands on these like
things that have such important impacts
in society
cool and that's that's really
interesting um nfcs as well was
something i've only yeah more recently
come across um and so it's i guess it's
really interesting just to kind of
explore the possibilities and to kind of
i guess see what happens
um but uh so speaking with generally
about just funding research um
this kind of leads more to you brian but
uh last week or the week before you
recently announced that you're i'm
helping to fund a new company called new
limits
which are going to be entering the
epigenetic reprogramming space i believe
um so i was just wondering if you could
explain the story behind that
yeah sure so um obviously as you can see
there's i have a passion for advancing
science and one of the things i've been
learning about a lot in the last few
years is longevity as well you know
i'm really fortunate to have had the
last 10 years building coinbase and it's
been such a great company and i think
it's just getting started and i think
um you know as the ceo of coinbase i
felt like i've developed this ability to
fund some new initiatives in the world
and basically do capital allocation into
interesting areas even frankly harder
more difficult areas um
you know i think if you make money in
software which is having this big golden
age right now you know i think you
almost have an obligation to go try
harder things in the world and help some
of those companies get off the ground so
as an investor and a board member i've
been
excited about doing something in the
longevity space i started hosting some
dinners with scientists over the last
year or so
and came together with this guy i've
known for a while blake byers
he
co-founded another really successful
biotech and was a investor in biotech
for a long time at google ventures
and he and i got more and more excited
about the epigenetic reprogramming space
as a really exciting area for longevity
you know there's lots of areas people
are looking at for longevity with
different supplements and exercise and
mental health and everything i think
those are really important but there's
almost a moon shot to be looked at here
which is can we actually
change how genes are expressed in all of
our cells to make them a little bit like
you know they're young again and so of
course the dna is the same in all of our
cells even though they differentiate
over time into skin and muscle and
neurons and whatnot but um with these
these transcription factors we can you
know
yamanaka got the nobel prize back in
2006 showing you could take a skin cell
and kind of reprogram reprogram it back
into a stem cell
so this has been
a lot of people over the last you know
four or five years have sort of been
thinking well what if we don't want to
go all the way back to a stem cell but
we do want to go a little bit back in
the in the cell of the life cycle of the
cell
and
i think there's a lot of interesting
research to be done here so this is not
intended to be um an institute that
we're endowing that's purely academic
but it's a for-profit company
it's going to seek to create therapies
that are more like intermediate targets
along the way you know imagine could we
rejuvenate maybe your immune system or
you know something in the eye right
these are more
still very difficult but um more
achievable goals over maybe like a
five-year time frame frame or three-year
time frame but the long-term goal would
be to say is there some kind of therapy
we could we could all take that would
rejuvenate tissue or organs throughout
our entire body
and be at least a big piece of the
puzzle toward um
longevity or uh you know
curing aging would be like the kind of
more ambitious way to put it but we
always have to be a little
cautious i think i love the idea of
having really ambitious missions but
then you don't want to turn people off
because there's a lot of folks in the
aging space that are sort of doing
pseudoscience and so
um yeah that's that's what we're doing
with new limit it's early days and we're
basically uh recruiting the founding
team and
more people for that team and we've got
some office space set up in in redwood
city california
awesome yeah so i mean i agree the sally
larry programming i think it's really
awesome and i'm just like with
gymnastics itself i mean i said uh
previously on my channel but it's one of
the topics that actually kind of got me
into biochemistry in the first place i
just think it's fascinating that um what
ourselves are capable of um so in terms
of um the
the company itself so it's primarily
gonna just be research to begin with i'm
trying to
further do basic research before trying
to find uh therapeutics from it
yeah that's right so you know i think
we've we're choosing some initial
indications and um there are again these
more like intermediate targets that we
could go for
i think the initial thing we'll be doing
is
basically seeing if we can reproduce
some of the existing science and then
scaling up the
the iteration
speed of how quickly we can
design an experiment run it collect the
data and have it inform the next
experiment right i think
one of the
one of the breakthroughs
that you know one of the ways you get
breakthroughs i think in this and we're
kind of doing it on an industrial scale
so it's hopefully not as constrained
in just like one lab with purely manual
efforts
but if we can increase the cycle time
there
either by you know there's many ways you
could increase the cycle time you could
choose a different animal model you
could have use aged animals you could do
sort of multiplexing you know you could
run multiple of these experiments in
parallel right and um there's a lot of
bioinformatics machine learning that we
can use there to sort of design um
you know help design the next experiment
and create this positive feedback loop
which hopefully iterates towards this
but i think if we're doing more we'll be
doing more basic science up front
but the goal would be eventually to get
those intermediate targets into clinical
trials develop real therapies that um
that get to market and help it help real
patients so
it's i do think there's a really healthy
discipline in
um
you know shipping real products and
don't don't make it like some you know
multi-decade grail quest or something we
want to have real products along the way
and you know an analogy i like to use is
spacex right like their ultimate mission
is to make the human race interplanetary
but in the short term they're like all
right let's get a let's get the
satellite into orbit and maybe we can
develop a revenue stream from that
that'll that'll help um fund the company
to do the next step in the next step
cool and so you mentioned things like
machine learning so like what kind of
scientists are you trying to recruit
like biologists by chemists uh data
scientists i guess the whole mix right
yeah so um there's definitely a machine
learning bioinformatics piece there's um
experimentalists and and scientists
there i think it's good to have really
close collaboration between them
um and then there's you know we're
hiring a head of r d like a
vp of ops or co so there's a couple um
you know executive searches there but uh
that's that's some of the initial team
i suspect the team would be
you know 25 people or so in the first
year or so
cool i mean i guess more generally like
is there anything else in the longevity
space that you also think is like quite
interesting at the moment
oh i mean there's there's a lot of good
companies out there in the longevity
space i mean there's actually a number
of other companies getting funded in the
in the epigenetic programming space
which is kind of i feel like there's
there's something happening there you
know it's like the there's a lot of
interesting smart people moving in that
direction
um
i could go through a whole bunch of
other companies but i'm not sure i have
like a perfect list off the top of my
head yeah
cool i'm gonna say i guess let's bring
it back into again um just a more
general question um as it's kind of um
this time of year somewhere to christmas
i was just wondering if you have any um
just more general advice for people
interested in this area of any maybe a
particular book that you've either read
or you're hoping to read um over the
holidays um yeah
so one of my favorite books is um by a
dutch scientist called um
dr dick schwab and it's called we are
our brains
um it was originally published in dutch
so it's kind of like awkward title in
english but um it's uh like kind of like
a manual to how your brain works like
from a neuroscience perspective and then
like cognitive psychology as well so
it's like amazing because like you'll
read this book and it's like
oh wow like
like it explains how anxiety works right
it explains like how ptsd works how like
different drugs work and um yeah it's it
uh i read it maybe the first time like
three or four years ago and it just
provided so much insight to me about how
like i actually think and so yeah i
would recommend everybody read it
because it's uh it's been super
beneficial for my own life
yeah there was one really good science
fiction book i read this year called
project hail mary
um that i would recommend then that
one's cool and then i read um
a couple of siddhartha mukherjee books
like about um
the emperor of all maladies like about
cancer and uh i think he had another one
on um
the gene yeah the junior school yeah
that's a good book i recommend that one
too
yeah
cool i would definitely be adding this
to my reading list um and so also i
guess kind of one from that as it's
always the start of a new year do you
have any like advice um i guess how best
can someone what can someone do to help
improve um
like um their life next year or like
something related to academia
well i mean one thing i like to do every
year is
i mean this isn't specific really
related to academia but i just like to
write down the beginning of the year
what are what are my goals for the year
what would be a great you know a great
year if i try to think about my life a
year from now and
usually i write down a number of
business goals and some personal ones
and it could be anything from as simple
as like
you know
get a dog to um
it could be like
health related or it could be
you know i want to i want to
have a hundred thousand people you know
using research hub every day right or so
it could be something specific like that
so
and then what i like to do is if you
have a goal for the year you kind of
break it down into each quarter and then
ideally you know every two weeks you
have some kind of a
or every day even usually when i wake up
every day i kind of write down if i only
got three things done today like what
would it be and i sort of think about
those long-term goals first and then is
there some what's the thing i'm doing
today it'll help move it towards that so
i like to sort of connect all those
things together
um but i don't know just like some good
combination of um
health and
relationships and fulfilling work
um
seems to be a good combination so
i if you do a little bit of that every
every day or every week um
that seems like a good combo for me i
don't know that's that's a big question
but joyce what do you think
uh so like more that academic realm i
think like taking the time to learn
about open science like i have a lot of
friends who are in phd programs right
now where it's kind of intimidating
because people are so worried about like
essentially just getting a job you know
it's so competitive like to take the
extra time to potentially like put your
career at risk by sharing things openly
like it can it can
it can be hard for an individual to do
um like i know a couple people who
aren't even really aware of like bio
archive and met archive and kind of the
whole like culture around pre-prints
just because like it doesn't make sense
for them to spend time doing it but um
just like one anecdote um which i think
is really powerful
um i had a friend who was a phd student
at university of maryland who had like
written a manuscript and thought it was
really good uh submitted to a bunch of
journals um
couldn't get published anywhere and then
they actually shared their paper on
bioarchive and without even marketing it
like they didn't like share it to
twitter like they didn't like put it on
reddit or anything like that but just
from being on bioarchive they actually
got other people to start sharing it
because others thought it was
interesting and then e-life was like oh
wow this is a cool paper like they've
reached out to my friend and was like
can we please publish your paper so
like uh open science like it can it can
feel like a little bit of like an
ethical type behavior i guess and a lot
of people like to frame it that way but
it can also be used as like marketing
for yourself so like for early career
researchers who want to put themselves
out there more taking the time to kind
of like see what you can do in the open
makes a huge difference even for
research hub like we're building in the
open we we have these weekly community
calls like brian mentioned that we
publish to youtube we have a slack
channel that anyone can join like help
share feedback and we've been able to
meet a lot of really cool people by
doing that so i think the more you put
yourself out there um the more you're
gonna um you know put up a bath signal
for other like-minded like individuals
to learn from you and network so yeah i
think open science is a really cool
thing it's worth taking the time to look
into
that's a good point you know
doing more work in the open i think it's
something yeah science could really
benefit from it's like joyce said
you know
even i think i put out a blog post um a
few years back about how to improve
science or something and just thinking
out loud and you know joyce joyce and i
think kind of connected he found that i
was even interested in that through the
blog post right or like
um
just
your youtube channel is a great example
of this
also eleanor it's like you're probably
learning some of this stuff and it's
like i'll just put it out there but it's
led to all these interesting connections
and somehow now we all got connected
right and so i do think there's a little
bit of this thing in science where
everyone's like ah they're very precious
about their work and like i don't want
to look stupid and so i'm going to be
really sure it's buttoned up and it's
proved that everything looks perfect and
it's it's almost like
risk averse right and they're like okay
i'm gonna finally put out something and
it's been two years but there's some
sort of a freedom that comes from doing
work in the open like in open source
software people often like they'll start
a new project
literally like the very first project
and they'll commit inversion control
you'd say this is my first uh commit
and they'll push it live to the whole
world like everybody can see it like
they literally just started the project
10 seconds ago and the first commit is
already live to the world and they're
doing work in the open because
there's something nice about tearing off
the band-aid it's and then you get
people who come in and see the project
and they that you might not have already
connected with and they'll give you
ideas as you're go as you're evolving
along the way so i think
once in a while like joyce was saying
too you'll you'll put out like if you
put out one thing every week
one of them will just be 100 x get 100x
the attention of everything else you've
ever done combined and you can you can't
really predict which one of those it's
going to be and so it's better just to
be prolific sometimes and put it out
there and then
it helps guide your work so you're not
operating in this vacuum for years
before you get any kind of feedback
yeah i completely agree and yeah you
both just provided really incredibly
useful in a five star um it's also i'm
very like grateful for you both coming
on today and speaking to me um so i'll
be putting the link to research hub in
the description but where else can
people find information that you'd like
them to go check out
yeah well
particularly your audience i mean we'd
love to have people join the longevity
hub on research hub and
you know if there's an interesting paper
you that you've read would love to have
you submit it there
and if you have any papers that you
already see on the site we'd love to
have you jump in and add comments or
discussion and in the open so people can
start to respond to it and think about
it
and you know if you're interested in
becoming an editor of the longevity hub
or another one we have an application
form you can google it research hub
editor
program i think we'll pull it up um
yeah but otherwise i think you can
follow us on twitter
at researchhub right joyce and we've got
the slack
with the community calls that we host
every week or two so you can join the
slack to sort of give feedback about the
product and the site as it's coming
together
if you see bugs or anything like that
but yeah joyce what else comes to mind
uh we have an email address hello at
researchhub.com that's easy to remember
i'm at researchhub.com
um but yeah i think that twitter is
probably the best place to send people
at research hub
yeah cool i'll be awesome to put those
links in the description as well so yeah
no thank you both for coming on today
it's been just great to talk to you
about research hub like i'm excited
about the future of scientific research
i think um it's good to always talk
about the problems but actually trying
to address them is something um
way harder to do and it's just great to
see that we're starting to make some
progress with that so yeah i'm really
excited that
you're both working on this
we couldn't be happier with uh what
you've been doing as well eleanor i feel
like it's awesome that like similar
minds are meeting here throughout across
the world on the internet so
thank you for everything you're doing as
well it's super cool
thanks
yeah the best part of this project is
being able to meet people like you i
feel like it's everyday i mean people
are so cool doing cool stuff in the
science space so yeah thank you again
for taking the time to have us no
problem and you know thank you and you
just said the message that yeah it's
great to connect and i'll see yeah
hopefully anyone watching uh help
connect as well um and come join
research
so i hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening
you